just 108 says would you rather become an
anime review Channel or stop watching
anime well Joey actually got offered
this exact conundrum in real life and
took one of the op yeah I picked the
correct one I would like to
think did you just read that just yeah
you bastard all right here here we go
here's here here's a fun one would you
rather watch only 5.0 and lower rated
IMDb movies or only watch 5.0 and lower
rated anime based on my anime list
movies cuz movies that are like dog [__]
are funny and Anime that are really bad
are under five are generally not funny
also uh it's like anime series right
that are fun that's longer than an
average movie so you'd be able to get
through true but the movie Faster I feel
like you know let's let's take like you
know IMDb movies versus my anime list
this is this is talking about
entertainment [__] right yeah what what
Conor just one of the [__] questions
he's a psychopath why would he write
that oh the Demi one no no below that
oh what kind of who comes up with that
Mick Mike are you good bro sorry g g was
explaining and all I could focus on was
that Mike said would you rather be in a
Battle Royale with all your friends and
family or be forced to strangle 100
innocent kids every day for the rest of
your life how would you even find 100
innocent kids I love how they have to be
innocent kids there of evil kids and
you'd have to do that every day why 100
You' run out of kids 100 kids that's it
Mike what's wrong with you you also
didn't balance this Mike this is so
badly balanced Mike you're a
psychopath Sorry God you're saying you I
could now now you just like [__] haed
out of [__] pocket hung strangling I
think Mike is Mike is like he probably
thought like 50 no i' do 50 there do 100
that okay but to go back to the the 5.0
one right like we'll get to that one
next I I want to that one I've seen a
lot of anime you want to answer that one
yeah I want to answer that one I thought
we were yeah I I've seen a lot of anime
that are 5.0 and below and I've seen a
lot of movies that are 5.0 and below and
on average of my experience I had a
better time watching the low rate of
movies like a bad movie is kind of fun
cuz you know it's going to be over in 40
minutes by the time realized it's so bad
like with with 5.0 and lower anime a lot
of them are just like so mid that it's
not even worth committing to like
they're not even the so bad that it's
good it's also so painful like watching
a physical actor be like in a scene that
is just bad is so much more funny
because it's almost relatable like you
can you can relate to the fact that this
is probably awkward and [__] for the
actor as well the anime the anime
equivalent to that is just aggravating
to watch yeah cuz someone had to
it's like someone [__] up either like
the music [__] up the voice acting is
bad the animation is horrible like it's
it's it's not fun to watch it's just sad
like whereas watching someone be bad at
acting it's kind of like this weird
catharus where you're like man I can
kind of relate and I sympathize which
makes it equally funny that they were
cool this out I I feel like I've seen
more badly rated movies that I actually
enjoy than badly rated anime that I
actually enjoy it's it's it's funny
because if I see a 5.0 in an anime
rating I'm like this [__] is dog [__]
yeah I think the worst rating you could
possibly have is five I don't think I've
ever seen anything like yeah if if
you're if an anime is actually like
technically mid like the actual
technical definition of the word mid
it's terrible the only thing worse than
a bad anime is a forgetta mid anime
which a lot of 5.0 and lower up yeah and
it's weird sometimes I've seen 5.0 or
like kind of like that kind of like
rating scale of movies and
ofas
justed it's a 5.0 it's
beic harm or generic uh is isai shut the
[__]
up why you why you got why you got arm
yeah that's the thing right so it's like
I would much rather just see like a
really like terrible movie that is just
so terrible that it's funny yeah rather
than just watching a bunch of shows I'm
going to forget immediately after I
finished watching it yeah so I'd take
the movies anyway all right yeah I take
the movie as well all right let's answer
the [__] psychotic one then you going
we've won so far would you rather be in
a Battle Royale with all your friends
and family will be forced to strangle a
100 innocent innocent kids every day for
the rest of your life what is your
opinion that won't possibly get you on a
watch
list well Joey them kids
[Music]
man so why are you killing
potentially again this again this is
just the uh Aaron question right yeah
thisin you you Aaron Jager
both both why not both actually why not
80% of all of them what if you what if
it's a battle royale with all your
friends and family or just a battle
royale with a 100 innocent kids would
that make it better it's not even a
battle royale but it' be a
massacre what are those kids going to do
I just fight back I just wanted to
answer this question cuz the Battle
Royale with your friends and family I
think would be pretty epic you know it'd
be an epic weight to go I don't think
I'd win you know but I mean I I would I
would argue a lot of uh especially Asian
families do this with family
Wheels that's so true so it's already
happening Y grandma dies like load up
the [__] fortnite
music where we dropping Grandma
yeah
holy [__] you have the [__] long lost
Uncle you haven't seen in 20 years s pop
in the map and you're like [__] [__] he
was worth how much what the [__] did you
sport in oh God damn all right move to a
different country every year or live in
America for the rest of your life oh
that's a doozy cuz moving
sucks so does
America uh but you well you have 193
countries to choose from right so you're
not going to cover every single country
in you would get so good at just living
in places for kind of short periods of
time it want be better if it was like
one month cuz then I could just get used
to not being in the same place all the
time what if you could just like instead
of having to go through the process of
moving let's say you could just like
spawn and have your place like have have
a different to easy have a different
place no then I definitely choose that
yeah is there hundred and like is there
okay how many how many years do we have
left that's 60 we're being assume 60
okay being really generous are there 60
different places countries in the world
that you think you'd be happy living in
yeah I'm down to try i' say yeah I'm I'm
down to try gives me enough time to
either I absolutely [__] hate it or I
like it it gives me enough time to
figure it
out but uh Living in America for the
rest of my life basically say I'll know
in a
week I could do America though I think I
could do it I can make work it depends
where I'm basically American it depends
where you are okay what if let's change
the question a bit okay what if it's
move to a different country every year
uh like or live in a different state
every month for the rest of your life
well [__] no I'm not going to choose
that that's that's psychotic I'm going
to pick that I I actually think I'd pick
Living in America for the rest of my
life over moving a different country at
a certain point there are different
things stop moving yeah at a certain
point there you know it would just be
have kids yeah I can't really have kids
or the kids will be really unhappy can't
have pets really cuz you're moving all
no you know you know a feeling where you
just have a house and you're like [__] I
can buy the furniture now and know that
this is the furniture that I want that
is going to remain uh instead of just
having Airbnb Furniture you know it's
there there's so many like micro things
that you take for granted about just
having a physical place that you know
you're going to be in for x amount of
years in your life you know and taking
that away I mean it's obviously exciting
to move to a new place but only you like
you you do that enough times and it just
kind of gets stressful yeah that you
can't your root now that you can't plant
your roots somewhere yeah I mean I there
would definitely be enough countries in
the world I think where I'd be pretty
happy living it for the rest of my life
but yeah yeah that now that you said the
whole moving process that does sound
like a pain in the ass yeah so all right
Americans you get the W this time [__]
sake coconut coconut asks would you
rather try to cuddle with a polar bear
or kill and eat a penguin with your Bear
Hands kind of question is this uh one of
them is you die or you get
food yeah I'm I'm sorry penguin you're
You're gone why the [__] would I try and
I die yeah this should just be would you
rather kill an either penguin or kill
yourself I'd rather kill and eat a
penguin actually I've listened to enough
Joe Rogan podcasts to know to know guys
Jonathan he eating a penguin gives G Jon
is a really good one actually right all
right what what is it would you rather
lose your taste buds or lose all of your
memories from the past five years of
your life
ooh both would be horrible both would be
horrible especially for us cuz the past
5 years have been pretty nice for the
most part for me I would choose lose my
taste
spots I don't know
actually I would choose lose my memories
for the past five years I can ask people
what what I did I can I just oh [__] I
just realized my wedding was in the past
five years yeah okay okay all trash tast
in the past five years caveat right to
make it more fair cuz I think losing
your taste B is a huge deal and I think
you know five years that you we can
probably think of some ways to make it
easy yeah yeah nobody knows you've taken
this deal not even you if you take the
deal to lose your memories Al so you're
not even aware you've lost your memories
you've lost your memories but you don't
understand why you've lost them right
okay uh which would make this probably
more traumatic but um yeah you just made
it the deal worse yeah yeah but I'm just
trying to say I think actually memory is
kind of stacked right now I think the
memories is too strong yeah see I think
my my logical reasoning of why I would
choose I would rather lose my taste Buzz
is because yes you lose your sense of
taste but you still have your sense of
smell which is kind of like taste [__]
Jo not this is why restaurants by the
way [__] He's smelling at the outside
even if you can't taste the food you can
still smell the food so it's kind of
like tasting no Joey yeah like cuz like
you know that experiment of like how
they like make you smell one food and
then they make you eat something that's
completely different and it completely
changes the way of how you taste that
food like it's called an old factory
system for a reason it's all connect
there's still taste being is a part of
no that's what yeah but like what I'm
saying is losing your taste buds and
only your taste buds doesn't necessarily
get rid of taste in general it's there
but just in spad Joey just goes to a
restaurant has one whiff and he's like
I'm satisfied I've eaten take it back
take it back oh oh I'm so full I
couldn't come with the [__] I couldn't
smell another bite I couldn't I possibly
could but if you lose all your memories
in the past 5 years then that's just
like there's no backup T just having an
all you can e like when he goes to the
gas station he's like I'm full I could I
could smell another drop yeah I'm good
I'm I'm I'm fulled up I think I would go
for the Memories really yeah no I think
it would just be sad because like okay
say for example even if someone was
there to like my sh on camera yeah but
even but like say you want YouTubers
making a hardon all
right I don't have any [__] pictures
as well what do I what do I have gone I
got something you have the friends you
have the friends that you had and that
will carry carry because I feel like
hearing those memories again would be
really sad because like a lot of those
memories would be fun but then you'd get
that sense of sadness of like well it
sucks cuz I don't remember experiencing
it you got to live without your taste
buds okay okay okay actually actually
let me choose losing my memories cuz I
can watch attackman Titan for the first
time all over again baby yeah I honestly
think about how many anime you can watch
it you can watch Arcane again for the
first time that actually was a good
point God you underestimate how little
shows I've watched in the past 5 years
there isn't a lot to rewatch my entire
life in Japan I wouldn't remember yeah
your entire life in Japan you would not
remember think about how and then how
confused would you be when you suddenly
wake up and you're like where the [__]
am I I guess I would know zero Japanese
as well yeah all the friends you made
here gone all the memories you made on
trash it's not like it's not it's it's
only the memories that are going the
friends are still going to be there
Japan's going to still be here you can
make new memories it's okay it's it's
like this does [__] it does suck but
like with your taste buds you live with
that [__] for the rest of your life I
don't think I would want to live on this
Earth if I couldn't eat nice food but
you can you can still smell
it I'm telling you you can still [__]
smell the
food and that's a big part of your like
eating food experience is smelling the
like eating something while you've had
like a stuffed nose is completely
different to just being normal oh it it
it's still completely different but it's
still is better that I can taste like a
little bit of it without taste buds you
remove one of the
little happiness you get every day
[__] gigantic Okay g well gigantic
whatever you know tasting that coffee in
the
morning it's it's some it's sometimes
it's the little W's we get every day
that helps us just [__] cope with the
rest of the [__] that's happening in our
Liv the little W's for me are like the
memories and experiences I have